we arrested these five bands and our
check out the rap sheets
Drax aka the destroyer since his wife
and family were killed he's been on a
rampage across the galaxy in a search
for vengeance Gamora soldier assassin
one run over a dozen counts of murder
rocket one run over 50 charges of
vehicular theft and escape from Locker
what how root it's been traveling
recently as Rockets personal house
plants slash muscle Peter Jason quill
he's also known as star-lord Kokosing
that himself mostly he's wanted largely
on charges of minor assaults public
intoxication
and fraud oh sorry
hey youtubers it's Charlie the full
guardians of the galaxy trailer finally
posted so I wanted to do a review this
morning we got a 15-second teaser that
included some of the Comic Con footage
that people had already seen including
that hooked on a feeling song but
overall it was great Marvel took a huge
chance on this movie normally they only
spend this kind of money on say like
Robert Downey jr. and the Avengers but
these are essentially be level
superheroes and that comic book hasn't
even done that well when you compare it
to stuff like the Avengers Thor Iron Man
let's talk about the new footage we
finally got to see some more Rocket
Raccoon and Groot including the Nova
Corps with john c reilly i like to think
of that scene as Marvel's version of the
usual suspects it's just meant to
establish them as galactic a-holes but
by themselves they are geniuses they are
the best at what they do so kind of
betrays the fact that they can be really
awesome whenever they do come together
and that's really when the climax and
the really awesome parts of the movie
you're going to happen when they
actually do start to work together the
movie's supposed to pick up when Peter
quill is nine years old so we'll
probably get at least one or two
montages of him growing up and then
putting the team together before that
john c reilly scene happens that's
probably later in the movie I was a
little bummed that we didn't get to see
some of the more important secondary
characters like Ronan the accuser Nova
and Nova prime but to be fair the first
trailer is always about that core team
so it's really just about showcasing
them so the second trailer will probably
have more footage of the other
characters really my biggest questions
right now are just plot related because
they did a really good job of showing
off visually what the movies gonna look
like basically like classic Star Wars
grimy and amazing we didn't get to hear
Bradley Cooper's voice as Rocket Raccoon
but we can kind of
sumit Vin Diesel's going to sound like
his group just because his voice is
already so gravelly they probably have
to change it that much I do kind of
wonder what Bradley Cooper's voice is
gonna sound like as Rocket Raccoon
Marvel and James Gunn said that he's
basically the heart of the film so I
can't wait to see some extended scenes
with the character but right now after
this trailer here are the top five
things that I'm looking forward to
seeing in the next trailer so number
five Karen Gillan speaking number four
Glenn Close as Nova prime that's
actually a really important character to
number three Lee pace as Ronan the
accuser I can't wait to see is a huge
character in the Marvel Universe and Lee
pace is amazing
number two Gamora beating the crap out
of someone we get to see some action
from her but she's supposed to be
flat-out crazy so I can't wait to see
some of that and the number one thing
I'm looking forward to seeing Rocket
Raccoon cracking wise but now it's your
turn let me know what did you think of
the trailer and what are you looking
forward to seeing most in the next
trailer in case you didn't see it I just
posted a big preview with character
breakdowns for the movie you can click
here to watch that and you can click
here to get my breakdown of the Captain
America Winter Soldier killer it's
almost here thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives